the eu's efforts to end its reliance on
russian gas are simply not enough that's
the warning from the international
energy agency which says the block is
set to have insufficient gas supplies to
see it through the winter if russia
turns off the taps the message came from
the iaea just as russia's gazprom
reportedly sent a letter to european
importers declaring force major on
deliveries down the nordstrom one
pipeline to germany the state gas
producer said that extraordinary
circumstances meant the resumption of
flows was beyond its control germany's
government says it's now considering
whether to extend the life of its three
remaining nuclear power plants to
alleviate the looming crisis meanwhile
the eu has just signed an agreement with
azerbaijan on monday to double its gas
imports to europe in the coming years
well let's get more on that european
commission president ursula fonda line
was at the signing ceremony in baku
which could see a 50
increase in gas from azerbaijan this
year
i want to emphasize three points from
our memorandum of understanding
the first is that we will double the
supply of gas from azerbaijan to the
european union
indeed with this mou we commit to the
expansion of the southern gas corridor
this is already a very important supply
road route for the european union
delivering currently more than eight bcm
billion cubic meters of gas per year
and we will expand its capacity to 20
billion cubic meters in a few years
well let's put those figures from ursula
fonda line into context because the iea
says that gas imports from all sources
outside of europe or outside of russia
even won't be enough to replace russian
supplies so let's have a look at this in
2021 russia sent
155 billion cubic meters of natural gas
to the european union the nordstrom 1
pipeline we've been talking about has
the capacity to send 55 billion cubic
meters in a year meanwhile azerbaijan
sent a total of 8 billion cubic meters
to the eu last year and under the deal
is now expected to deliver still only 12
billion this year so that wouldn't even
come close to replacing flows from
nordstrom one let alone
russia as a whole
so let's discuss this further with our
russia specialist aaron tilton thanks a
lot for joining me in the studio to talk
about this so we've had this letter from
gazprom to russian importers calling
force major saying it can't guarantee
that deliveries will restart down nord
stream one how likely is it looking that
they won't
well i mean so far right now we don't
really know what russia's justification
for this they haven't actually made any
direct statements to that um however
that does seem to be the most likely
outcome when you're talking to
international experts here in europe and
also european leaders as well um they've
long had the supposition that this is an
attempt by the kremlin to put pressure
on the eu and more specifically on
germany especially as we're moving
towards the colder months you have to
remember germany's dependent for around
50 of its gas imports on the russian
federation and russia is really looking
to kind of
cause the support for the ukraine
in the current conflict to dwindle
and it seems like this is i mean as one
economist we spoke to yesterday put it
you know the first opening salvo in a
gas war so it does really seem like
experts are expecting russia to keep the
taps to um close when it comes to this
pipeline is this the opening salvo in a
broader gas war how likely is it looking
that the iea's fear that europe's going
to have to do without russian gas this
year is actually going to come to
fruition in the winter well i think that
really kind of depends upon what happens
in the next weeks and months you have to
remember gas is still coming from the
russian federation to the european union
this is just one pipeline it is
incredibly important important pipeline
for germany but i do think this is uh
kind of them you know just kind of
sending a little you know test balloon
or a canary in the coal mine trying to
see exactly where this is going to go
they want to see what this is going to
do to gas prices and they want to see
how the public and also european
politicians and specifically german
politicians react to this move and of
course you know we're already starting
to feel the pinch here i mean gas
contracts here in berlin have already
tripled and quadrupled in the last
couple weeks and as we're moving towards
winter when things get colder and gas
becomes more important you're definitely
going to see those prices
start to increase and i think the
kremlin is going to be watching the
noises coming out of berlin and coming
out of paris in the coming months to see
if this is actually a tool that they can
use to exert pressure on the european
union moving forward so i mean it's
anyone's guess if they're actually going
to go for a full and complete stop it's
really going to determine how european
industry and politicians react in the
next coming weeks okay aaron tilton
thanks for keeping us up to date on that
thank you